So for 60 percent I want to do per cent, or divided by 100. I know dividing by
100 moves the decimal place 2 places left. So I get point 6, or 6 10ths. For all
these percents I'm going to need to move thee decimal two places left and divide
by 100. So I get 5 10,000ths. Here again I'm going to move the decimal two
places left. And I get .5302, here when I move the decimal 2 places left I get 2
extra 0's and my decimal point ends up here. So I get this number. Again I move
the decimal 2 places left and I wind up with 30. It's probably easier to
remember how to go from a percent to a decimal. You just think about what the
word percent means. It means per 100, or divided by 100. So, to go from a
decimal to a percent, we need to undo that dividing by 100. So we multiply it by
100. So 52 times 100 is 5200%. Multiplying four thousandths by 100 gives me 4%,.
and multiplying 1.35 by 100 gives me 135%. Notice that each time I convert a
decimal to a percent, the decimal place moved two places to the right. Now that
we can work with decimals and percents, let's go back to our shoe problem.